Gemüse aus dem Supermarkt ist einfach
richtig teuer geworden und deswegen
kommen hier 12 Tipps mit denen die
einfach euer eigenes Essen anbauen könnt
und richtig viel Geld sparen nicht alle
Leute haben den Garten aber wenn ihr
einen Garten habt dann überlegt doch mal
ob es nicht viel schlauer wäre Gemüse zu
ernten als Rasen zu gehen also für mich
ist die Sache ziemlich eindeutig wenn
ihr kein Garten habt dann schaut mal wo
ihr irgendwelche Pflanzgefäße aufstellen
könnt also wo würde vielleicht noch ein
Blumentopf hin passen nur vielleicht
eine Paprika Pflanze drin wachsen kann
wo könnte man den kleinen Apfelbaum
hinstellen vielleicht habt ihr ja für
sowas Platz vielleicht reicht es auch
nur für einen kleinen Balkonkasten wo
man ein bisschen Salat anbaut aber
selbst seinen eigenen Salat anzubauen
spart einem ersten schon mal richtig
Geld und zweitens ist es einfach ein
richtig tolles Gefühl wenn man merkt man
ist einfach sein eigener kleiner Farmer
das ist einfach ja es macht einfach mega
Bock mit den Enden
es macht einfach mega Bock mit den
Händen in der Erde zu wählen und wenn es
mal ganz kleines bisschen ist dann
treibt es vielleicht ein bisschen was
dazu bei dass man sein Portemonnaie
entlastet und dabei richtig Spaß hat
muss auch nicht unbedingt teure
Blumentöpfe kaufen um sein eigenes
Gemüse darin anbauen zu können jetzt
kommt so ein bisschen eine krasse Story
also ich bin mit 18 schwanger geworden
da war ich noch in der Schule ich hatte
absolut gar kein Geld konnte auch nicht
arbeiten gehen als ich dann Baby hatte
weil ich war in der Schule und danach
habe ich mich um mein Baby gekümmert in
der Zeit haben wir aus einem Supermarkt
Mülleimer aus einem Container gegessen
wir sind danach zehn und haben uns da
unser Essen geholt weil wir sonst
einfach nicht über die Runden gekommen
wären und das war die Zeit in der ich
richtig angefangen habe zu gärtnern weil
wir einfach kein Geld hatten uns richtig
gutes Essen zu kaufen und man kann dabei
so unfassbar viel Geld sparen man kann
auch viel Geld ausgeben indem man teure
Hochbeete kauft und so weiter aber was
ich damals gemacht habe war z.B einfach
zu einem Restaurant zu gehen von dem ich
wusste dass die so richtig große
tomatensoßen Dosen hatten die habe ich
mir da einfach geholt kostenlos hat ein
Loch unten reingebohrt und habe da drin
meine Kräuter angebaut habe die an
meinem Gartenzaun aufgehängt um einfach
den Platz noch besser nutzen zu können
man kann wenn man es drauf anlegt so
viel aus dem machen was man hat und
deswegen überlegt einfach mal was
könntet ihr recyceln was könnte man
verwenden als Pflanzgefäß das vielleicht
jetzt noch irgendwas ganz anderes ist
wie kann man z.B aus Abfall Sachen
machen die man gebrauchen kann zum
Beispiel könnt ihr eure Pflänzchen in so
Weintrauben Schalen die ihr vielleicht
übrig habt wunderbar vorziehen da müsst
ihr keine Pflanztöpfchen kaufen ein
anderer Tipp der damit Hand in Hand geht
ist dass ihr nicht fertige Pflänzchen
aus der Gärtnerei kauft weil die viel
viel teurer sind sondern dass sie die im
Haus selber aushält also wenn ihr jetzt
z.B Salat anbauen wollt dann könntet ihr
auf dem Wochenmarkt sind sie kaufen aber
viel schlauer ist es wenn ihr euch
einfach Saatgut holt und das im Haus
selber aussieht danach draußen pflanzt
das ist zwar ein bisschen mehr Arbeit
aber man spart sich enorm viel Geld wenn
man das so macht viele Leute die in
Töpfen anbauen denken dass man jedes
Jahr neue Erde in die Töpfe einfüllen
muss weil die alte Erde ja verbraucht
wäre das stimmt überhaupt nicht was viel
viel cleverer ist ist wenn ihr euch eine
große Wanne nimmt irgendwas was ihr hat
und alle Erde aus allen Töpfen da
reinkippt sobald die Saison vorbei ist
also jetzt so im Winter kippt ihr da
alle Erde rein dann vermischt ihr alles
packt ein bisschen Dünger rein um eure
Erde wieder aufzuladen und dann verteilt
ihr die wieder auf die einzelnen Töpfe
so habt ihr die richtig schön
aufgefrischt ihr habt so eine eigene
kleine Fruchtfolge sozusagen also ihr
baut nicht jedes Jahr im selben Topf
wieder die gleichen Pflanzen an so dass
ich da Krankheiten und Schädlinge
festsetzen können und alles ist wieder
schön frisch und ready für die neue
Gartensaison wusstet ihr dass ihr Dünger
gar nicht kaufen müsst sondern einfach
selber machen könnt zum Beispiel indem
ihr eine Brennessel ja auch ansetzt
Brennesseln wachsen quasi an jeder Ecke
ihr werdet auf jeden Fall welche
bekommen Handschuhe anziehen dann packt
ihr die einfach in den Eimer am besten
kein Metallgefäß verwenden oder einen
holzfastenden Plastikeimer irgendwas was
sie abdecken könnt damit da keine
Insekten reinfallen packt Wasser drauf
am besten Regenwasser aber zur Not geht
auch Leitungswasser und dann rührt ihr
einfach einmal am Tag um und so könnt
ihr euch eure eigene Brennesseljauche
herstellen
die anfängt so ein bisschen zu müffeln
das wird auf jeden Fall passieren dann
packt mal Urgesteinsmehl rein einfach so
ein zwei Hände voll das hilft schon um
den Geruch zu binden damit das nicht
mehr so eklig stinkt danach einfach die
Brennesseln rausfiltern und dann könnt
ihr das ganze als Dünger Konzentrat
verwenden also immer dann mit Wasser
verdünnen das ist ein richtig toller
Dünger der eure Pflanzen von innen
heraus stärkt und kräftigt in der euch
keinen einzigen Cent kostet wenn ihr
irgendwie könnt dann fangt Regenwasser
in eurem Garten auf Wasser wird immer
knapper und die Sommer sind in letzter
Zeit sehr sehr heiß und trocken gewesen
also fangt euer Regenwasser auf und
nutzt das in eurem Garten der spart ihr
enorm an der Wasserrechnung ihr könnt
eure Beete aber auch so anlegen dass die
Wasser unterirdisch speichern z.B indem
ihr Komposter anlegt wie das
funktioniert zeige ich euch in meinem
dreiteiligen Mini Kurs der heißt das
Gemüsegarten Bootcamp da könnt ihr euch
gerne für anmelden das kostet euch null
Euro und bringt euch enorm weiter in
eurem Garten also schaut gerne mal in
den Link vorbei der ist oben in den
obersten Kommentar angepinnt oder auch
hier oben in der im Gemüsegarten
Bootcamp zeige ich euch zum Beispiel
auch wie ihr eure Beete so anlegt dass
ihr kaum noch jäten müsst das ist auch
eine riesige Arbeitsersparnis und macht
es einem so so leicht das ganze Jahr
über Gemüse aus dem eigenen Garten zu
ernten ohne ständig in den Supermarkt
rennen zu müssen ich achte immer darauf
dass ich die Ressourcen die wir haben
sinnvoll nutzen zum Beispiel nutze ich
den Rasenschnitt oder auch Laub das
sowieso im Garten anfällt für meine
Beete als Mulch da kann man die Pflanzen
im Winter schön einpacken damit sie
nicht erfrieren man kann den ruhig auf
die Beete packen damit im Sommer viel
weniger Wasser verdunstet der muss ich
verrottet nach und nach und wird zu
Dünger für unsere Pflanzen füttert die
Bodenlebewesen das ist also rund um eine
tolle Symbiose genauso mache ich das
aber auch mit anderen Sachen wenn ich
irgendwo ein altes Blech rumfliegen habe
dann nehme ich das als Rasenkante für
meine Beete wenn ich irgendwo ein Haufen
Steine habe die ich eigentlich loswerden
möchte dann überlege ich was ich daraus
im Garten bauen kann zum Beispiel kann
man daraus auch eine Beet Umrandung
machen also da immer kreativ sein und
den Fokus darauf haben was habe ich was
brauche ich und wie kann ich das was ich
habe vielleicht für das nutzen was ich
brauche mein Garten ist außerdem ein
Kreislauf das heißt die Abfälle die hier
entstehen sei es der Hühner Mist seit
der kohlrabi-strunk sei es der
Heckenschnitt werden kompostiert und
dann wieder zu neuen Nährstoffen für
meinen Garten man kann das sogar machen
wenn man auf dem Balkon wohnt einfach
die ganzen Bioabfälle in den bukashi
einmal packen da erntet man dann am Ende
einen Flüssigdünger und eine wundervolle
Erde die man wieder verwenden kann um
die Pflanzen anzubauen und das ist ein
richtig toller Kreislauf den man auf
jeden Fall für sich nutzen sollte man
kann z.B auch eine Wurmkiste haben die
habe ich auch auf meinem Balkon zu Hause
das heißt alle Küchenabfälle die ich zu
Hause habe ich wohne ein bisschen weiter
weg von meinem Garten packe ich einfach
da rein und dann verwandeln die Würmer
den nach und nach in Wurm muss und das
ist ein extrem tolles Zeug mit dem ich
dann auf meinem Balkon wieder neue
Pflanzen anbauen kann wenn man mal so
den Jahresverlauf betrachtet dann haben
wir ja eine Zeit des extremen
Überflusses im Sommer und eine Zeit in
der es viel Tage ist und viel weniger zu
essen es gibt aus unserem Garten und
auch aus der Natur nämlich den Winter
und deswegen mache ich im Sommer immer
ganz viel haltbar für den Winter so
sparen wir auch enorm viel Geld und sind
einfach unser eigener Laden also im
Winter habe ich trotzdem noch Apfelmus
aus meinem eigenen Garten weil ich im
Sommer daran gedacht habe das haltbar zu
machen und wenn ihr vielleicht gar
keinen eigenen Apfelbaum habt dann
schaut ob es vielleicht irgendwo
Apfelbäume gibt wo die Leute einfach mit
dem Ernten nicht mehr hinterherkommen
ich glaube das kennt jeder oder dass man
Bäume sieht wo die Äpfel an den Bäumen
verfaulen das ist so traurig da gibt es
z.B auch die mundraub-app die euch
runterladen könnt oder die Aktion mit
dem gelben Band wo man Apfelbäume
markieren kann die sozusagen zur Ernte
freigegeben sind und so kann man sich
auch ohne eigenen Garten oder ohne
eigene Bäume ganz viel Essen von überall
her beschaffen Filme dass man überhaupt
nichts bezahlen muss wenn man Gemüse
anbauen will dann muss man natürlich
einiges Wissen und einiges beachten und
deswegen habe ich euch hier ein Video
zum weiterschauen verlinkt indem ich
euch erkläre Schritt für Schritt für
absolute Anfänger wie Gemüse anbauen
eigentlich funktioniert damit das dann
auch klappt also ganz viel Spaß geht
raus und macht die Welt ein bisschen
grüner und wir sehen uns im nächsten
Video wieder macht's gut bis dann
tschüss